Mark: I-I dont know how to sync it up from this screen
Oh I guess I could just.. Okay..Wait..
...hang on...lemme go...
Mark: boot boot boot                                                                                                   Jack: It's good if your mouse is on screen
It's not, so let's do this!
[Bob laughing]
Mark : I'm a kitty cat.
Wade : Yaaay!
Jack: Such a fricker.
Mark : You're a fricker, fricking fricker-
Jack: count the time on screen.
Mark: Oh. One.
mark: zero.
*all laugh*
audience: oh boy -_-
Jack: *Laughing* Nailed it!
Mark: Thank you!
I tried real hard on that one.
*all still laughing*
Bob: Holy fuck
Jack: You actually had a countdown timer; you're like, "I don't know how to sync this."
Jack: "This is impossible!"
*Mark laughs*
Jack: The easiest syncing you've ever had to do
Mark: Shut up! I didn't know.
Wade: With all the disdain in your heart. "ONE!"
Jack: "One... Got it! Cool!"
Mark: It's ok, I know what I'm doing. I'm editing this one. It's cool.
Mark: Okay. Should I explain the game? Did any of you explain the game to the people watching?
All: No
Bob: Not even at all.
Mark: Alright, this is Orcs Must Die. It's a new MOBA/ survival game/stuff
where you play with your friends and try to kill the enemy dead.
Alright, so my role is 'pillager'. *to Jack, Bob and Wade* I'm not talking to you assholes, I'm talking to them.
My role is 'pillager'. I go get, steal supplies and kill people in the back and then uhm... I don't know
Jack: He's the coward role.
Mark: Hey, I'm not the coward!
Bob: He's the one that doesn't help us with anything and will have a very low score at the end of the game in all of
Bob: the important categories.
Mark: No! I'm going to have the best score at the end of the game, you just wait!
Jack: He'll just have the best score because he just avoids everything.
Mark: SHUT UP!!!
No I don't! Just 'cuz I'm running away currently right now, doesn't mean that I avoid everything.
Bob: That sounds like what that means.
Mark: Nooo.
Jack: And you play a character who turns invisible and doesn't want to get into the battle
Mark: Shush!
You don't know me! Let me be me
and I'll do my thing and you do your thing,
which is hopefully not suck.
Jack: I'm slapping a door with magic.
Mark: Wow *Laughing*
Bob: With magic!
*Scattered laughter*
Jack: I'm magicing!
Mark: Ow... Uh-oh.
Jack: Go, spirits of the underworld!
Jack: Kill the dude!
Derek (Bob): Did you cast magic missile into the darkness?
*Mark and Jack laugh*
Mark: I get that reference! i get it!
Bob: Com'ere Mo-bot. You gon' die. You gonna die mo-bot
Mark: ... Wow
Wade: Oh god, Gabriela deals no damage!
Jack: Aah, I leveled up already.
Mark: My-MINE! MINE!
HAHAH!
My kill.
hehehehehehehweho wah heh ha
Wade: Ow. Oh, get out of here!
Bob: Let's take down this guardian right now, Jack -- oh god, run away!
Jack: Get'em! Get'em! Kill 'em!
Jack: 'Kay, he's locking on
Jack: No, let's not do that.
Jack: Let's jungle for Mark!
Bob: Oh yeah!
Bob: haaaaaaah
Jack: Cause he's a stupid.
Bob: Thanks for all your help, Mark.
Mark: You're stu- I, I AM helping!
You guys aren't helping with Mo-bot.
You're letting me get him.
I guess thank you.
In a way. *Jack chuckling*
Mark: Here we go. Got 'em!
Mark: Oh god! Ah oh oh hey help help
Jack: Damn I'm gettin' all kill assists- stop stealing everything!!
Bob: Stay in here, Lizzybot
Mark: I'm not gonna help you, I'm gonna help myself.
Mark: Uhoh- She blonked!
Wade: They've got a level two portal already!
Mark: Shut up, it's fine!
Ow.
Bob: Mark should do something about that.
Jack: Wade, stop freaking out!
Wade: [freaking out sarcastically]
Jack: Wade's in the back like, just like "guys we're gonna lose!"
Wade: We'll be fine if if B-Bill-Bill tank hadn't stolen my person!
Jack: I'm gonna suck my own health for mana.
*Mark laugh*
Jack: *growling* Sustenance...
Mark: That's an interesting way to describe that, but ok.
Mark: So Jack's sucking himself in the corner over there
while we're trying to make the victory here.
Jack: I want to suck myself.
Bob: There's two of them over there, Je-ack.
Jack: I know.
Jack: Ow, god it hurts.
Jack: Oh, Bob I hurt.
Wade: Oh NOT Lancebot, not now!
Jack: I still can't believe that Wade has a fuckin' bot archnemesis.
Mark: Yeah, he's that much of a loser.
Wade: Oh god, I got all of the arch-nemesis!
Mark: You don't HAVE any arch-nemesis!
You're literally not their main focus.
Wade: I'm their main focus...
Bob: Come the fuck here Lazybot
Jack: Get him! Get him!
Mark: Haha! I stole the kill again!
Jack: Kill assist AGAIN?
Mark: Yehaha!
Jack: You just rolled in and take the kill!
*Mark's evil laugh*
Jack: What a bitch!
Mark: I'm a pillager! I'm a kitty cat pillager.
Mark: Don't mind me.
Jack: You're an asshole.
Bob: Hey,
Bob: Mark opened-
Jack: AHHHHHH
Bob: Mark actually open the second gate!
Bob: I guess I'll go put some things in it.
Mark: Yeah, duh! I'm like super cool.
*Jack laugh*
Jack: "I'm, like, the best!"
Mark: Didn't you guys know?
Bob: Jack, can you put your glyph down yet?
Bob: You-you got dem coins? For that glyphs?
Jack: No, I need 1250 and I only have 995.
Mark: Ow ow.
Bob: Scrub.
Mark: AAahh, Guardian!
Jack: Shut your pee hole!
Mark: Noo!
Bob: Scrubs.
Jack: Shut it all up!
Mark: This is my-
Jack: [interference]
Mark: This is my video! If I shut up, it's not going to be very interesting.
Jack: Not you, I'm talking to Bob! He needs to shut the sh-
Mark: Oh.
Jack: Oh wait, Krogan meat! Krogan meat! Go get it!
Mark: Whic- Oh wait it's on the other side.
Bob: Oh yeah.
Bob: I'll come help you, Mark.
Jack: If you go fast, you'll get it!
Bob: I'll come help you.
Wade: Umm... They have enemies in our middle tunnel.
Jack: Yeah, well, you're-
Mark: They're all going for it. Every team member is going for it right now.
Bob: Team by...!
Mark: Alright, I'mmunna-
Mark: I'mmunna be right there as soon as I break this box.
Jack: I go....I go help?
Mark: I'll be right there.
Wade: UM. Why are you all here? Get out of my house!
Mark: I literally told you tha-
Bob: Holy shit!
Mark: -they're on the way
Bob: See ya Mark!
Mark: [laughs]
Jack: Comin' to help!
Mark: OHH that's a LOT of them.
Jack: See, it's all there.
Jack: Yeah.
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: I'm- This is going to kill me.
Mark: This is going to kill me. I'm gonna die.
Mark: I'm dead-I'm runnin' aWAY AH AH I CAN'T RUN
Mark: AHH
Jack: [laughing]
Jack: I gotcha!
Bob: Mark, I got you.
Bob: I got you
Mark: Thank you for th-
Jack: AHHHHHHH
Mark: -heals
[laughter]
Mark: I think-I think we should-
Bob: Wish I could kill this goddamn
Bob: fucking bear
Wade: Ohh noo
Mark: That didn't-see-yes.
Jack: Fuckin' LANCEBOT DIE JESUS CHRIST
Wade: I need a gun to put down traps in awhile.
Bob: Lancebot's gon' die.
Mark: Is he?
Jack: crap, crap crap crap
Mark: Nah, he's gonna run away like a bitch.
Jack: crap crap crap
Bob: How is he so fast?!?!
Mark: Ow ow ow! Dead I'm dead I'm dead. I'm dead, I'm SO dead.
Jack: Yeah.... Hogarth is FAST
Mark: AH BUT I GOT THAT KILL hueh huehhuhhuhuhuhuh
Jack: FOR FUCK'S SAKE! KILL ASSIST AGAIN? I hate you.
Mark: hueheuhhuehoohohohohoh
Mark: Need to be better, man.
Jack: YAY! I got one.
Mark: Yay.
Wade; Okay,
Mark: Okay, we gotta get that Krogan Meat now.
Jack: Did we get the meat? No we didn't.
Mark: Because they all-
Mark: Lancebot ran away like a little bitch
Jack: Weeeee!
Bob: Yeah, I'm gonna go back to the attack glade and you guys get the meat.
Mark: Alright, we're gon' get it.
Mark: Can I steal this kill too?
Jack: NYAAAGHHH
Mark: AH! I'm low on health and didn't even realize!
Jack: Die you-
Wade: -all of them right here!
Mark: Oh god, I'm dead.
Jack: God dammit!
Mark: I'm so dead.
Bob: Mark-Mark gon' die.
Mark: No I'm not.
Mark: You don't know that.
Jack *mumbles something about everyone sucking amid the interference*
Bob: Seems like you're gonna die.
Mark: A-Ah!
Jack: Oh god, Lancebot's here. HELP!
Mark: I was stealthed!
Mark: Come on! Come on!
Mark: So close!
Mark: Ha HAA! I got 'em!
Mark: ehehehehehehe
Mark: [evil laughter]
Wade: Our guardian's dead too
Jack: HELP ME!
Bob: Uh, do you have enough coin for your glyph yet, Jack?
Jack: Yes.
Bob: We should do that.
Mark: I've got no health, but I'm tryin' to help you, Jack
Mark: Cause I'm a-I'm a friend
Jack: Yeah, I've got no health either.
Mark: I'm a good friend.
Jack: This is bad.
Mark: Oh god.
Jack: get 'em get 'em get 'em
Mark: YEAHH
Jack: Yes!!
Mark: Another kill for meee!
Bob: Goddamn, dude!
Mark: I'm doing good this round.
Bob: ooOH GOD
Mark: Even though I'm very very VERY close to death.
Mark: I'm going to be killed by a gnoll, how bad is that?
Bob: That's not good.
Jack: We need Krogan Meat!
Mark: I couldn't get it, I was about to die. I'm going back to recover.
Jack: I-I-I died tryin' to get it
Bob: There's fucking three of you guys over there, how hard is this?
Mark: I'm-I got two health!
Jack: Lancebot started showing up and started...
Jack: opening anuses.
Mark: [laughing]
Jack: He was like "Let me inside that B, I love you!"
Jack: I was like, "Nooooo!"
Mark: Well that's-
Bob: That does SOUND really bad.
Mark: It doesn't sound that bad actually, he's kinda nice about it. So...like...y'know.
Jack: My glyph is down. And...eh...
Bob: Awesome.
Jack: Wave's comin' out.
Bob: I will take this lane, you take that lane?
Mark: I'm helping!
Mark: Look, I'm helping!
Jack: Ok.
Bob: Thank you Mark, good job. *insincerely*
Mark: Thanks, man!
Jack: [interference] you little BIYATCH
Jack: Okay, I'm gonna head for the Krogan.
Mark: Yeah, I'm gonna help too. I'm just-I just ran Ivy out of there so hopefully I'm gonna be able to...
Jack: 'lo Bob!
Mark: Ha-hah!!!
Bob: Hey, how's it going?
Jack: Good.
Mark: Uh-oh.
Jack: Ow, ow, STOP it
Mark: This guy SUCKS by myself, can you guys come help?
Jack: Stop the hurting, o-ow
Jack: I'm comin'!
Jack: I'm slow
Mark: Be-Be faster,
Bob: I'm about to break through a gate.
Mark: -please!
Bob: So....leave me alone.
Jack: KYOP
Mark: So what the Krogan meat does -
Mark: -And once again I'm not talking to you assholes -
Mark: What the Krogan meat does, is it allows you to get a boss-
Bob: [laughing]
Mark: HEY I killed him, why do YOU get the meat?
Mark: That's not fair!
Jack: 'Cause you stole all my other fuckin' kills!
Mark: NO!
Mark: Screw YOU!
Bob: Yeah. It's so-
Bob: -frustrating when someone takes the spoils of what you've been working on for so long, isn't it?
Jack: YEAH, doesn't it suck?
Mark: Hey! I earned all those kills!
Mark: Just 'cause you guys were so bad that you couldn't even keep up with me
doesn't mean that you need to complain about what I'm doing.
Jack: Shaddup, we're doing meat.
Jack: Go put a boss in!
Mark: No.
Wade: Yeah!
Mark: I don't wanna.
Mark: whoa.
Jack: Oh! We're almost there! We're almost there! Almost there!
Mark: Ah, shit!
Jack: Where'd he go?
Mark: Dammit, I almost got Dustybot.
Mark: Jack, don't go in there!
Mark: Jack, it's death!
Jack: [Interference] I'm not going in there, I'm taking potshots.
Mark: Alright, here we go.
Jack: C'mere Lancebot!
Mark: Alright.
Mark: Hang on.
Jack: God, I have no fuckin' mana with this dude. Ever.
Wade: Mmkay...
Mark: AHH ha hAH HA ha ha!
Mark: Aw, kill assist.
Wade: Nice kill!
Mark: Kill assist? It might as well not have happened.
Jack: MY kill this time!
Mark: Just 'cause you got range...
Bob: Don't tell him 'nice kill', that just encourages him.
Wade: Oh.
Bob: Think I'm about to get a solo kill on Mobot.
Wade: BAD kill.
Bob: C'mon.
Bob: C'mere, you motherfucker!
Bob: Nope, don't, don't target me, guardian. You don't need to do that.
Mark: AH Kill Assist?? This is bullshit!!
Bob: Goddamnit!
Jack: [mechanical laughter]
Mark: I'm like, I'm like way better than you, Jack.
Jack: I'm just hanging around you now to do it on purpose.
Mark: 'Cause you got range, such crap!
Bob: [infectious laughter]
Jack: Hey, you take them out close, I'll take them out far.
Jack: We all work together...
Jack: And we'll... have a Merry Christmas.
Mark: I don't - it's not even close to Christmas, but okay.
Jack: SHUDDUP
Mark: Ow, Lancebot hurts!
Bob: Let's take down this Guardian!
Jack: Yeah, Lancebot sucks.
[Jack, turning into an unintelligible robot]
Wade: Yeah, you don't belong here!
Bob: He's doing a lot of damages.
Mark: Did anyone summon a boss, or did we totally forget about that?
Jack: Oh!
Bob: Nope, no one did that.
Wade: No, there's another-there's another-
Mark: Yeah, we totally forgot about that.
Wade: -er, erp
Mark: Yeah, no one summoned a boss.
Jack: [coming in and out] He doesn't do anything anyway.
Jack: Oowwww.
Bob: I will go back and put in a boss for the next wave.
Jack:~*~[interference]~*~
Mark: Yeah, I'm attacking the Krogan right now. No one better steal my meat!
Mark: No one by the name of Jack better try to jack my meat!
Bob: Mark, I want your meat.
Bob: [seductive gargling]
Mark: No, Jack, not again! I'm tired.
Mark: Ah, Lancebot's gonna kill me!
Wade: Well, that sounds a lot like...
Wade:...someone else...
Mark: ... huh?
Bob: Oh, we actually didn't get a boss, guys!
Mark:Yeah, I- That's what I said!!!!
Bob: or did someone put it in?
Mark: I just said that!!!
Bob: Why did you ask if someone put the boss in if there was no boss?
Mark: And then I answered my own question!
Mark: It was a rhetorical like-
Bob: I stopped listening once I realized you were being a jeeeerrrrkkk.
Mark: It was like-
Jack: Go get the Krogan meat!
[Mark laughs]
Mark: Well, that's not very nice.
Jack: Kill th-oH GOD they're all here!
Mark: Ow!
Jack: ow, ow
Jack: Get the meat!!!
Jack: For fuck's sake!
Mark: Goddamnit it was my meat!
Mark: I hope you die!
Mark: I hope you die?
Jack: I am gonna die.
Wade: ♪ -the play♪
Mark: I'm not gonna help you I'm just-
Wade: ♪ -the play ♪
Mark: I'm just hanging around you hoping you'll die
Jack: oh god oh god
Mark: Aw, come ON!
Jack: Oh god oh god I'm running
Jack: Oww!
Mark: Yay! My meat!
Mark: Immuna go!
Jack: Take it!
Jack: GOO!!
Jack: You don't have any health either!
Mark: Shuddup!
Mark: I have 11, that's enough to get it in.
Mark:  eehlelelelelelel- YEAH!
Bob: C'mon Mark, get it in!
Mark: I did it!
Mark: Ah, shit!
Jack: Okay, I'm just about to respawn, I'll put a boss in.
Mark: Oka-
Mark: NO I want the credit!
Mark: I want everything!
Jack: FUCK YOU!
Mark: awww...
Jack: You didn't put it in when I didn't get anything!
Wade: You get nothing
Wade: And you're gonna like it.
Mark: Well, you put the meat in!
(Bob: I'm gon' die!)
Mark: So it was YOUR responsibility!
(Bob: auuhhhhh)
Mark: Take responsibility for your meat!
(Wade: Bye Bob.)
Jack: fuck you.
Mark: [heavy breath]
Jack: Place the boss.
Mark: Alright, fine.
Jack: Go Earth Defender, Guardian of the World!
Mark: Aw, not Earth Defender.
Bob: Good teamwork everybody
Jack: Ah cool, just got it in.
Mark: Earth Defender's so weird and stupid!
Jack: shuddup.
Wade: Man, if only our Jungler was gathering, we could have level three minion portals.
Mark: I was gathering! And killing. But also gathering.
Jack: Gathering meat does not count.
Wade: Oh! Oh no!
Interference Jack: -DUTY-
Bob: That must be why we have level three minion portals.
Mark: Hang on.
Mark: I got it.
Mark: I'm on it!
Wade: Mark, Lancebot's in the middle, he's almost dead.
Mark: Okay, got it.
Wade: Meet you there
Mark: Missed him.
Mark: I-I totally whiffed.
[Wade cracks up]
Mark: [laughing now] I completely missed him!
[Wade continues to crack up]
Wade: Got him!
Wade: No I don't!
Jack: No, the other thing!
Mark: I literally did a sweet spin kick in midair
Mark: and TOTALLY missed him.
Bob: You gon' die, Mobot!
Bob: You gon' die, motherfucker!
Bob: Aw, come on.
Jack: Oh nooo!!!!
Jack: Fucker!
Bob: Fuckin' gate!
Jack: Pushin' through the gate, pushin' through the gate, quicker, quicker
Bob: I'm gonna push past to get that motherfucker.
Bob: Oh, he's gone!
Jack: Ran away.
Jack: What a little bitch!
Jack: Oh god, heheh
Jack: A Kobold just flew past my head.
Jack: Stop attackin' the scarecrow!
Mark: Dammit dammit dammit
Jack: That's not a thing!
Bob: This scarecrow thing is annoying.
Mark: Ow! Ugh, Lancebot just-euhh- jackslapped me!
Mark: I got- Euh! I got Lizzybot! I'm outta here baby! I'm out!
Jack: haaa
Jack: [gravelly voice] You do not belong here.
Jack: Look at Mobot over there, taking potshots at us.
Jack: Go away Mobot, you little bitch!
Mark: What a dick.
Mark: Wait, which lane is doing better?
(Jack: I hate him so much.)
Mark: Which lane is pushing farther?
Bob: Right now, we've got the boss in the long lane.
Mark: Okay - euuuhhh uhhhhuhuhh
(Bob: The right-er- bottom)
Wade: No no no no no no no!
Jack: C'mon, c'mon, c'mon c-Aw, he was like three hits away!
Bob: Don't worry Jack, we're about to-We're about to get through the gate, whatever man.
(Jack: GAHH I hate that motherfucker.)
Mark: Yeah, whatever man, jesus.
Bob: Mobot can do whatever he wants.
Mark: Why don'tcha shuddup, you bitch?
Wade: Ugh, both their minion portals are level three?
Jack: NOT whatevers.
Wade: OH GOD!
Mark: No it's fine, we're almost there too.
Mark: Don't worry, your pillager is here doing REAL good work.
Jack: We are level three - go put shit in!
Mark: I'm about to die I'm about to die!
Mark: My real good work is about to be ended!
Bob: I'm not, I'm not - I wanna keep pushing with the, uh, Guardian. Or the uh, Earth guy.
Jack: I dunno what you're talking about. I'm talking about [interference eats Jack again]
Mark: Jack, you keep cutting in and out, we can't hear ya.
Jack: [YELLING IRISH INTERFERENCE]
Mark: ... What??
[Bob's laugh]
Mark: I got it.
Mark: I think he said 'go upgrade the thing'.
Jack: I DID say that!
Bob: I think that's what he said to do.
Jack: I'm not cutting in and out, you suck!
Wade: I dunno, that doesn't sound like something Jack would say.
Mark: Alright, I got it. I got the perfect wave 'cause I got the healing hobgobles behind 'em.
Wade: That sounds fancy.
Jack: What's our guardian doing?
Bob: I dunno, he's just sorta standing there bein' a dick.
Jack: or our boss?
Bob: The Earth boss is kinda of glitchy once he breaks into pieces
Bob: I don't think the AI works quite right.
Jack: No.
Jack: Y'think? [laughs]
Bob: He's sorta just standing there.
Mark: Hey. Come back.
Jack: We're going to get the guardian though
Bob: Maybe.
Bob: We're almost out of-
Bob: gUUuuuh
Bob: bosses, to keep his attention.
Bob: Oh god, Mobot's coming.
Jack: And then you got a guardian.
(Mark: Oh, where're you goin'?)
Jack: I've no mana!
Bob: Suck your life or whatever.
Mark: Yay!
Jack: That makes me very vulnerable!
Mark: [laughs] Jack is very vulnerable when he's sucking himself
[mature laughter]
Wade: I mean...
Jack: EARTH GUARDIAN, DO YOUR THING!
Wade: Raise your hand if you're surprised!
(Wade: and no one raises their hand)
Bob: You don't know if I raised my hand.
Mark: Yeah, you don't know how many people watching raised their hands.
Wade: Bob, I know you.
Wade: OWWWW WHERE DID YOU COME FROM YOU HELLMONSTER!?
Bob: Mobot, you are not running away this time, you piece of shit!
Mark: I got your help!
Mark: I got your back there, Wade.
Mark: Finish 'em off!
Mark: But I'mma steal the kill, don't steal my kill - but help.
Mark: Dammit, you stole my kill!
Jack: AHH hit him! Aha
Wade: Oh god I'm gonna-dUHHWUHHUH
Mark: Uh oh. I'mmuna die too.
Wade: Bye Mark!
Mark: Ah shit ah shit ah shit
Jack: I'm lovin this game!
Mark: Ah shit!
Wade: Oh god
Mark: Ah shit dude!
Bob: Guys, you can go around that, y'know right?
Wade: Ugh, everything terrible that could've happened, it did.
(Jack: I opened it up for the minions!)
(Bob: Ah, whatever.)
Jack: cause your stupid
Mark: Hey Wade-
Bob: Let's score some pounts!
Mark: Wade, at least I made it out alive.
Mark: That's what really matters.
Wade: Yeah, yeah.
Wade: That's all that matters.
Bob: That;s the important thing.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: I guess.
Mark: OW Hero-seeker arrows.
Wade: Oh, they-they got a lot of people.
Jack: We're about to be-
Bob: Ooh, Somebody-
Jack: We're about to be big score.
Bob: Somebody put shamans in this wave.
Mark: I did that!
Bob: That's cool.
Mark: I put heal-y shamans!
Bob: Shamans look coool.
Mark: Thank you, Bob!
Mark: That means so much!
Mark: Everyone's been calling me an assho- aww.
Jack: DON'T ENCOURAGE HIM!
Bob: They're almost all dead, but they look cool.
Mark: Aw, but they're heal-y shamans!
Bob: But they died to JUST the traps, basically.
Mark: Shhhh your sp-SHUSH!
Mark: They're heal-y shamans!
Bob: Jack, we got a Dustybot behind us over here.
Bob: It's your counter -ozial(?)
Wade: C'MERE LANCEBOT HOW LIKELY THE ODDS ARE IN YOUR FAVOR
Mark: I finally got Lancebot, the douchehole.
Jack: Big score, big score!
Mark: WHoa, we're about to win, holy hell!
Jack: Big score!
Bob: No, you're not going anywhere motherfucker. I'mmuna kill you
Jack: No you're not.
Bob: Or I'm gonna get a kill assist, thanks Jack.
Jack: No problem.
Bob: I think we're going to win on this next wave if it goes like the last one did.
Mark: Yeah, probably.
Bob: PROwabl
Mark: Prowably.
Mark: 'Cause I doubt they can rally a defense quick enough.
(Jacktopher Walken: Wow, that is crazy!)
Bob: C'mon minions, c'mere!
Wade: AUUUHFUH
Bob: C'mere!
Wade: Look, I killed the crockamooch!
Mark: The crockaboot?
Bob: Ah, there's the crockahoomuh.
Mark: Noo, my kill! NOo, MY kill!!
Bob: Mobot you are not going to escape this time
Mark: Noo, MINE Mwahahahaha
Wade: There's a lot of-
Bob: Oh, come on!
Mark: I literally blocked your arrows with my body so I could take the kill!
[laughs]
Bob: you suck.
Jack: YOU HAVE ELEVEN KILLS? You fuckin' kill stealing bitch!
Mark: I'm a pillager! Isn't this my job?
Jack: NO
Mark: I placed like two traps - I was helping?
Mark: I was helping.
Mark: I was REAAAALLY helping, guys.
Bob: Jack and I won the game, so...
Mark: Dammit, Lizzybot!
Bob: whatever.
Mark: Oh no no no no no! Come ooon!
Wade: Uh, I kept them from winning the game?
Mark: hahahahaHAHha
Bob: [laughing] Bitch!
[More of Bob's magical laughter]
Bob: Alright well, the game's over in like 30 seconds.
Mark: Niiiice!
Mark: We did it! I did it! All by myself!
Bob: Yes excellent work, Mark, you definitely did it all by yourself.
(Jack: No, no)
Jack: C'MERE STANNUSBOT YOU'RE ALMOST DEAD
Mark: Yaaayyy~
Jack: NOO!
Mark: Yaaaaaayyy!
Mark:Yayyy!
Mark: YAAAYYY
Bob: Alright!
Wade: YEAH! YEAH!
Wade: YEAH!
Wade: Go little Wadey go!
Mark: Yeah, this game's ludicrously fun.
Mark: And also to save time: check out Bob, Wade, and Jack's channel
Mark: We all played a separate round over on their channels, I'll just say that now.
Mark: So, thanks guys for guiding me to victory!
Jack: Fuck you.
Mark: Aww.
Wade: You're welcome.
Mark: Thank you, Wade!!
Wade: Don't forget: they can play for free.
Mark: Fuck you, you're welcome.
Mark: Yeah go to orcsmustdie.com
Mark: You can find the game.
[Laughter]
Mark: I earned a thousand donkey fat!
Mark: Yay!
Bob: Alriiiiight!
Wade: Yaaaay, it's like what you already had for brains, or something.
Mark: WHOA BOB!
Jack: Bob was the best rated player!
Mark: Bob, you got a higher score than me!
Bob: wrek wrek wrek wrek wrek
Bob: 'Cause I did what I was supposed to do the whole time.
Jack: I was the best in placing glyphs
Bob: And also I got eight kill assists.
Bob: EIGHT kill assists!
Mark: [laughs]
Mark: But I got 12 kills!
Jack: Yeah, put the five kill assists from me, and the eight from Bob. [Laughs]
Wade: I got four.
Mark: Jack-
Mark: [giggles] Oh man.
Mark: Wade, you died three times? You bad.
Wade: I would've been so much better with Smolder- look at the Smolder person! 0, 1 and 0?
[laughter]
Jack: Don't blame Smolders!
Wade: Must not know how to play or he/she does not know how to play Smolder like I do.
Mark: Well, they did get highest damage delt
Mark: to minions.
Wade: Yeah, cause they're- that the best-
Wade: because they-
Wade: they-the-th-
[laughter]
Jack: [laughing] that's cause they the thing with the...YEAH.
Mark: Okay, alright.
Mark: I will see you guys later,
Mark: and I'll see YOU in the next video!
Mark: Buh-byee!!!
[LOUD FART]
Jack: Bye!
Wade: Bye!
[From Markiplier Animated | SUPER MARKIO GALAXY]
Oh, don't roll! NO! oh God! AAAAH!
(Blubbering noises)
[from HEYYEYAAEYAAAEYAEYAA | Prop Hunt #27]
Mark: lets sing it together
Jack: oh yeah
Mark: Splish splash I was takin a bath
Jack: [late] splash i was takin a bath
Mark: in a rubber ducky-
Jack: bumbumbumbum Splish spla-
Mark: - shove it up my bum
Mark: oh
Wade: Whoa whoa whoa
[Jack n Bob lose it]
The End